Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 37-year-old Jeff Shockling was watching television at his mother's house shortly after 7pm on Sunday, November 6, 2011. when he heard the doorbell ring. It was an unexpected sound to hear at that time of day. Jeff's mother lived in a rural area in Caldwell, Ohio.
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2011年11月6日星期日晚上7点刚过，37岁的杰夫·肖克林（Jeff Shockling）正在他母亲家看电视，这时他听到了门铃声。在一天中的那个时候听到这个声音很意外。杰夫的母亲住在俄亥俄州考德威尔（Caldwell）的一个农村地区。
Strange visitors to the home were rare, and known ones would just let themselves in rather than knock or ring the doorbell first. Jeff also thought it was odd that he hadn't heard a car pull up, meaning that whoever was at the door had arrived on foot. suspecting that another member of the family was playing a prank on him, Jeff asked his nine-year-old nephew to go and see who was there. The boy got up and went to the door, while Jeff continued watching the game show Jeopardy. A moment later, Jeff's nephew came running back and told Jeff,
家里很少有陌生访客，熟人通常会直接进来，而不是先敲门或按门铃。杰夫还觉得奇怪的是，他没有听到汽车驶来的声音，这意味着门外的人是步行来的。杰夫怀疑是家里的其他成员在跟他搞恶作剧，于是让九岁的侄子去看看是谁。男孩起身走到门口，而杰夫继续看着游戏节目《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）。片刻之后，杰夫的侄子跑了回来，告诉杰夫，
there's a guy at the door, he's been shot and he's bleeding right through. Still believing this was part of a prank his younger relative, had come up with, Jeff and nevertheless went to the front door. Standing in the doorway was a man Jeff had never seen before. He looked to be in his late 40s with a solid build, a short salt and pepper beard and a shoulder length grey street hair. The man's face was pale and he fidgeted anxiously while holding his right arm across his body. His right shirt sleeve was soaked in blood and so was his pantle.
门口有个男人，他中枪了，血流不止。杰夫仍然认为这是他年轻亲戚搞的恶作剧，但他还是走到前门。门口站着一个杰夫从未见过的男人。他看起来有40多岁，身材结实，留着短的灰白胡子，灰色的头发长及肩膀。男人的脸色苍白，他焦急地扭动着身体，右手横在胸前。他右边的衬衫袖子被血浸透了，裤子也是。
leg below. David Paulie was ready for a fresh start. For many years he had been a man of consistency. The 51-year-old from Norfolk, Virginia, had married his high school sweetheart, Susan, after the two had parted ways for a time. David adopted Susan's son Wade and became a stable influence in the boy's life. David modeled to Wade what a regular routine looked like, eating the same breakfast every day, and then going to work his 9-to-5 job as a warehouse manager and truck driver for a building materials distributor. But after almost 20 years of working for the same company, David was suddenly left adrift after they had to downsize. He struggled to find another long-term position, instead working
腿部下方。大卫·保利（David Paulie）准备重新开始。多年来，他一直是一个生活规律的人。这位来自弗吉尼亚州诺福克的51岁男子在与高中恋人苏珊（Susan）分开一段时间后，又与她结婚了。大卫收养了苏珊的儿子韦德（Wade），并成为了这个男孩生活中稳定的影响者。大卫为韦德树立了常规生活的榜样，每天吃同样的早餐，然后去一家建筑材料分销商做仓库经理和卡车司机，过着朝九晚五的生活。但在为同一家公司工作了近20年后，大卫在公司裁员后突然失去了方向。他努力寻找另一份长期工作，转而从事
various jobs here and there. This became even harder after the financial crisis of 2007 to 2008, which was the most severe global economic crisis since the Great Depression almost a century earlier. The subsequent recession led to companies going out of business and a shortage of jobs for blue-collar workers like David. David's personal relationships also began to suffer. Eventually, in 2009, David and Susan divorced. David moved in his older brother Richard and his sister-in-law, sleeping in their spare bedroom. The trio got along well, but David was looking for something more permanent. He was eager to get back on his feet and find a place of his own so he could properly begin the next chapter of his life instead of feeling like a guest in someone else's home.
各种零工。在2007年至2008年的金融危机之后，这种情况变得更加困难，这是自近一个世纪前大萧条以来最严重的全球经济危机。随后的经济衰退导致公司倒闭，像大卫这样的蓝领工人工作短缺。大卫的个人关系也开始受到影响。最终，在2009年，大卫和苏珊离婚了。大卫搬到了他哥哥理查德（Richard）和嫂子家，睡在他们的客房里。三人相处得很好，但大卫想要一个更永久的住所。他渴望重新站稳脚跟，找到属于自己的地方，这样他就可以适当地开始人生的下一个篇章，而不是感觉像住在别人家里的客人。
While working short-term temp rolls and occasionally having to borrow money from friends and family, David kept his hopes up for something better. At the men's Bible study sessions he attended regularly, he prayed to find a steady job. He also searched actively, turning to the internet to look for his next possible career. On Sunday, October 9, 2011, David was trawling job listings on the website Craigslist
在从事短期临时工作并偶尔向朋友和家人借钱的同时，大卫对更好的生活抱有希望。在他定期参加的男性圣经学习小组中，他祈祷能找到一份稳定的工作。他还积极寻找，转向互联网寻找下一个可能的职业机会。2011年10月9日星期日，大卫正在分类信息网站Craigslist上浏览招聘信息，
when one in particular caught his eye. Wanted. Caretaker for Farm. Simply watch over a 688-acre patch of hilly farmland and feed a few cows. You get 300 a week and a nice two-bedroom trailer. Someone older and single preferred, but will consider all. Relocation a must. You must have a clean record and be trustworthy.
这时其中一条特别吸引了他的注意。诚聘。农场管理员。只需看管一片688英亩的丘陵农田并喂养几头牛。每周300美元，外加一辆不错的两居室拖车。优先考虑年长且单身者，但所有申请都会考虑。必须搬迁。你必须有清白的记录并且值得信赖。
This is a permanent position. The farm is used mainly as a hunting preserve, is overrun with game, has a stocked three-acre pond, but some beef cattle will be kept. Nearest neighbor is a mile away. The place is secluded and beautiful. It will be a real getaway for the right person, job of a lifetime. If you are ready to relocate, please contact ASAP. Position will not stay open. The job ad immediately appealed to David Pawley. It would provide accommodation and enough income to live off, plus David loved the outdoors and a quiet life. Although he had close friends and family members he loved, he was content with being left to
这是一个长期职位。该农场主要用作狩猎保护区，猎物众多，有一个存有鱼类的三英亩池塘，但也会饲养一些肉牛。最近的邻居在一英里外。这个地方偏僻而美丽。对于合适的人来说，这将是一个真正的世外桃源，一生难得的工作。如果您准备搬迁，请尽快联系。职位不会长期空缺。这则招聘广告立即吸引了大卫·保利。它将提供住宿和足够的收入来维持生活，而且大卫热爱户外活动和安静的生活。虽然他有他深爱的亲密朋友和家人，但他满足于
his own devices. The ranch was situated in the foothills of the Appalachian Mountains, a scenic location where David could enjoy the natural world. David also had a slightly hippy-ish look with wavy shoulder-length hair and a bushy mustache, and he wasn't keen on changing his style for a more straight-laced position. If he was living alone on a ranch, then it wouldn't matter how he looked. The only catch was that the ranch was in the southern part of Ohio, two states away from where David currently resided in Virginia. But this didn't deter David at all. His lifelong best friend, Chris Mall, had moved to Ohio a couple of years earlier after his own divorce and was happy there. David and Chris had been frustrated.
独处。牧场位于阿巴拉契亚山脉的山脚下，这是一个风景优美的地方，大卫可以在那里享受自然世界。大卫看起来也有点嬉皮士风格，留着波浪状的齐肩长发和浓密的胡子，他并不热衷于为了一个更刻板的职位而改变自己的风格。如果他独自住在牧场上，那么他看起来怎么样就无关紧要了。唯一的缺点是牧场位于俄亥俄州南部，距离大卫目前居住的弗吉尼亚州有两个州之遥。但这并没有阻止大卫。他一生的挚友克里斯·莫尔（Chris Mall）在离婚几年后搬到了俄亥俄州，并在那里生活得很开心。大卫和克里斯一直是
friends since high school and always remained in contact despite life taking them in different directions. The men were so close that they talked up to 50 times a day. They spoke so frequently that they even purchased walkie-talkies for the sole purpose of chatting with each other. If David moved to Ohio, he'd be able to see his friend more often. David replied to the job listing, writing, I'm 51 years young, single male, I love the outdoors. I currently live in Virginia, have visited Ohio, and I really loved the state. Being out there by myself would not bother me as I like to be alone. I own pickup truck, so hauling would not be a problem.
高中以来的好朋友，尽管生活将他们带向了不同的方向，但他们一直保持联系。两人关系非常亲密，每天通话多达50次。他们通话如此频繁，以至于他们甚至购买了对讲机，专门用于聊天。如果大卫搬到俄亥俄州，他就能更经常地见到他的朋友。大卫回复了招聘信息，写道：我今年51岁，单身男性，热爱户外活动。我目前住在弗吉尼亚州，去过俄亥俄州，我真的很喜欢那个州。独自在那里生活不会困扰我，因为我喜欢独处。我有一辆皮卡车，所以搬运东西不成问题。
I can fix most anything, have my own carpentry tools. If chosen, I will work hard to take care of your place and treat it like my own. A few days later, David received a reply from the ranch owner, a man named Jack, who was also a preacher. Jack said that he'd received more than a hundred applications for the job and had narrowed his list down to three candidates. David was one of them. Jack had a few more questions for David, including whether he'd ever been arrested for a felony. David assured him that he had a clean record. Jack warned that the ranch didn't have cell coverage and asked if David was okay living in relative solitude.
我几乎什么都能修，有自己的木工工具。如果被选中，我会努力照顾好你的地方，把它当作我自己的。几天后，大卫收到了牧场主杰克（Jack）的回复，他也是一位牧师。杰克说他收到了100多份工作申请，并将名单缩小到了三名候选人。大卫就是其中之一。杰克还有几个问题要问大卫，包括他是否曾因重罪被捕。大卫向他保证自己记录清白。杰克警告说牧场没有手机信号，并询问大卫是否愿意过相对孤独的生活。
David confirmed that he was. Jack said that he'd let David know if he'd gotten a job by 2pm that Friday, making a clear that if David was hired, he'd need to start right away. David's excitement at learning he'd made the shortlist was visible to those around him. His brother Richard noticed how David looked happier and more animated than he had in a long time. When Friday came, David sat waiting by the phone. It didn't ring. David resigned himself to the fact that Jack must have chosen someone else. Then, hours after the deadline had passed, a call came through.
大卫确认他愿意。杰克说他会在那个星期五下午2点前通知大卫是否得到了这份工作，并明确表示如果大卫被录用，他需要立即开始工作。大卫得知自己进入候选名单后的兴奋之情，周围的人都看得出来。他的哥哥理查德注意到大卫看起来比很长一段时间以来都要快乐和活跃。星期五到了，大卫坐在电话旁等待。电话没响。大卫不得不接受杰克一定选择了别人的事实。然后，在截止时间过去几个小时后，电话响了。
It was Jack. David had the job. David was ecstatic. Wasting no time, he packed all of his clothes and most treasured possessions into a U-Haul trailer that his church had lent him the money to rent. Then on Saturday, October 22, he hopped into his Blue Dodge pickup truck and started the drive north to Ohio. David spent the night at a hotel in the neighboring state of West Virginia.
是杰克。大卫得到了这份工作。大卫欣喜若狂。他没有浪费时间，把所有的衣服和最珍贵的财物打包进了一辆U-Haul拖车里，这辆拖车是他教会借钱给他租的。然后，在10月22日星期六，他跳上他的蓝色道奇皮卡车，开始向北驶往俄亥俄州。大卫在邻近的西弗吉尼亚州的一家酒店过夜。
The plan was to meet Jack for breakfast the following morning at a chain restaurant in the Ohio town of Marietta. From there, Jack would take David to the ranch and show him around. Before going to sleep that night, David called his friend Chris Moore for a chat. Chris wished David good luck for his first meeting with his new employer and asked him to get in touch after he was settled in. He also told David to forward on his address as soon as he had it. David still didn't know exactly where the
计划是第二天早上在俄亥俄州玛丽埃塔（Marietta）镇的一家连锁餐厅与杰克共进早餐。从那里，杰克会带大卫去牧场并带他参观。那天晚上睡觉前，大卫给他的朋友克里斯·莫尔打电话聊天。克里斯祝大卫与新雇主的第一次会面好运，并让他安顿下来后联系他。他还告诉大卫一旦有了地址就转发给他。大卫仍然不知道
ranch was located, just the general area, and Chris wanted to drive down to visit the following weekend. But the next day, Chris didn't hear anything from David. He tried reaching out to him via his walkie-talkie and was met with silence. For two friends who spoke dozens of times every single day, this was a sudden and unexpected change. When David found out he'd gotten a job, Chris. Chris was the first person he called, saying it was the best thing to ever happen to him. The fact that he wasn't reaching out to let Chris know how the job was going, raised immediate alarm bells. Chris called David's brother and got a contact number for David's new boss, Jack. He then called Jack to ask how David was doing. Jack reassured him that David was
牧场具体在哪里，只知道大概区域，而克里斯想在接下来的周末开车去探望。但第二天，克里斯没有收到大卫的任何消息。他试图通过对讲机联系他，但得到的只有沉默。对于两个每天通话几十次的挚友来说，这是一个突然且意想不到的变化。当大卫发现他得到工作时，克里斯是第一个他打电话告知的人，说这是他一生中发生过的最好的事情。他没有主动联系克里斯告知工作进展的事实，立即敲响了警钟。克里斯给大卫的哥哥打了电话，拿到了大卫新老板杰克的联系电话。然后他打电话给杰克询问大卫的情况。杰克向他保证大卫
settling in well and he just left him with a list of chores to take care of. He's He said he'd let David know that Chris had called when he saw him the next day. Despite this reassurance, several more days went by with no word from David. Chris called Jack again, and this time, he had some unexpected news. Jack said that when he'd arrived at the ranch that day, David had repacked all of his belongings into his pickup truck. David told Jack that he'd met a guy in town who was going to work. on a drilling rig in Pennsylvania, and David had decided he'd do the same.
安顿得很好，他刚给他留了一份要处理的杂务清单。他说他明天见到大卫时会告诉他克里斯打过电话。尽管有这种保证，又过了几天，大卫还是没有消息。克里斯再次打电话给杰克，这一次，他得到了一些意想不到的消息。杰克说，当他那天到达牧场时，大卫已经把他所有的财物重新打包进了他的皮卡车。大卫告诉杰克，他在镇上遇到了一个要去宾夕法尼亚州钻井平台工作的人，大卫决定他也去做同样的事情。
Chris didn't believe this for a second. He knew there was no way David would have left Ohio without letting him know. By the time two weeks had passed with no word from David, Chris phoned David's twin sister, Deborah. The two siblings had always been close. After Deborah married her second husband, she relocated into state. but always stayed in touch with David. She was one of the first people he called after receiving his new job. David had told her his new boss was a preacher,
克里斯一点也不相信。他知道大卫绝不可能在不告诉他的情况下离开俄亥俄州。当两周过去而大卫仍无音讯时，克里斯给大卫的双胞胎妹妹黛博拉（Deborah）打了电话。这对兄妹一直很亲密。黛博拉在与第二任丈夫结婚后搬到了外州，但一直与大卫保持联系。她是他在得到新工作后第一个打电话告知的人之一。大卫曾告诉她，他的新老板是一位牧师，
and it felt like he was being spiritually directed towards finding peace. Deborah was happy for David, but she'd made him promise to visit her for Christmas in two months' time, as she didn't like the idea of him spending the holiday alone. When Deborah received Chris's call, it underscored her own growing concern. David had stayed in touch with Deborah during his journey to Ohio, and she'd asked him to phone her after he was settled in at the ranch. She hadn't heard from him since. Deborah tried calling David herself, but all of her calls went through to voicemail.
感觉他正受到精神上的指引去寻找平静。黛博拉为大卫感到高兴，但她让他承诺在两个月后的圣诞节去探望她，因为她不喜欢他独自过节的想法。当黛博拉接到克里斯的电话时，这加剧了她日益增长的担忧。大卫在前往俄亥俄州的旅途中一直与黛博拉保持联系，她曾让他安顿在牧场后给她打电话。从那以后她就再也没有收到他的消息。黛博拉试图亲自给大卫打电话，但她所有的电话都转到了语音信箱。
She left several messages, which became increasingly panicked and desperate as to the call. time went on. Deborah promised to David she would find him, saying, I'm going to bring you home, no matter what it is. The stress of the situation caused Deborah to lose her appetite, and she struggled to sleep. She spent several days trying to track her brother down by calling the hotel he'd stayed at on his way to Ohio and the business he'd hired the U-Haul trailer from. Neither were able to shed any life, on David's whereabouts. Without a location for the ranch, Deborah was unable to progress further in her search. Then, about a week after receiving Chris's call, Deborah suddenly recalled something.
她留下了几条信息，随着时间的推移，这些信息变得越来越恐慌和绝望。黛博拉向大卫承诺她会找到他，说：“无论发生什么，我都要带你回家。”这种情况带来的压力导致黛博拉食欲不振，难以入睡。她花了几天时间试图通过给大卫去俄亥俄州途中住过的酒店以及他租用U-Haul拖车的公司打电话来追踪她哥哥的下落。两者都无法提供关于大卫下落的任何线索。由于不知道牧场的位置，黛博拉无法在搜索中取得进一步进展。然后，在接到克里斯电话大约一周后，黛博拉突然想起了一件事。
David had told her that the ranch was in a town called Cambridge. Deborah went to her laptop computer and typed Cambridge, Ohio, into Google. A website for the town's local newspaper poppour. up and Deborah clicked on it, then started scrolling through recent articles. One that was published three days earlier on Tuesday, November 8, caught her eye. The headline read, Man says he was lowered here for work, then shot. Case file will be back shortly.
大卫曾告诉她，牧场在一个叫剑桥（Cambridge）的镇上。黛博拉走到她的笔记本电脑前，在谷歌上输入了“俄亥俄州剑桥”。该镇当地报纸的网站弹了出来，黛博拉点击了它，然后开始滚动浏览最近的文章。一篇在三天前，即11月8日星期二发表的文章引起了她的注意。标题写着：“男子称他被诱骗到这里工作，然后被枪击。案件档案稍后更新。”
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. On Sunday, October 9, 2011, 48-year-old Scott Davis was scrolling through Craigslist when he came across the same job ad that had caught David's eye. For the past 15 years, Scott had been living in South Carolina, but he'd grown up in Ohio and his mother still lived there.
感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。2011年10月9日星期日，48岁的斯科特·戴维斯（Scott Davis）正在浏览Craigslist，这时他看到了那条吸引了大卫注意的同一则招聘广告。在过去的15年里，斯科特一直住在南卡罗来纳州，但他是在俄亥俄州长大的，他的母亲仍然住在那里。
Her house was run down and in desperate need of repair. Scott and his fiancé both agreed that he should move back to Ohio to assist his mother for a while. Scott ran a landscaping business, and as it was getting close to winter, there would be little landscaping work in South Carolina anyway. When Scott spotted the Craigslist ad seeking a living caretaker at a 68-acre cattle ranch in Ohio, it sounded perfect. The work sounded easy enough that he'd still have time to help out his mother. Scott typed a reply to the ad. Just over a week later, on Monday, October 17,
她的房子破旧不堪，急需维修。斯科特和他的未婚妻都同意他应该搬回俄亥俄州去照顾他母亲一段时间。斯科特经营着一家景观美化公司，由于快到冬天了，无论如何南卡罗来纳州的景观美化工作都会很少。当斯科特看到Craigslist上招聘俄亥俄州一个68英亩养牛场住家管理员的广告时，听起来很完美。工作听起来足够轻松，他还有时间去帮助他的母亲。斯科特回复了广告。一周多后，即10月17日星期一，
he received a response from the ranch owner, Jack. Jack liked the sound of Scott and said it would be fine if he spent the weekends at his mother's. He asked Scott whether he owned a truck or any farm tools and also requested a photocopy of his driver's license for a background check. Scott provided the copy and assured Jack that he had everything required. After a few more emails back and forth, Jack offered Scott the job. Scott packed a trailer with his belongings, including clothes, stereo equipment, tools,
他收到了牧场主杰克的回复。杰克对斯科特很满意，并说如果他周末去他母亲那里也没问题。他问斯科特是否有卡车或任何农具，并要求提供驾照复印件以进行背景调查。斯科特提供了复印件，并向杰克保证他拥有所需的一切。在又进行了几次电子邮件往来后，杰克录用了斯科特。斯科特用拖车装载了他的财物，包括衣服、音响设备、工具，
and his beloved Harley Davidson. Jack had encouraged him to bring the Harley, telling Scott the area around the ranch was gorgeous and perfect for motorcycling. In early November, Scott hitched the trailer to the back of his pickup truck and headed for Ohio. On the morning of Sunday, November 6, Scott pulled up at a diner called Shoney's in the town of Marietta. He'd made plans to meet Jack there for a breakfast meeting before heading to the ranch where he'd be living and working. When Scott entered the diner, Jack was already waiting with a tall young man who looked to be in his mid-to-late teens. Jack introduced the boy as his nephew.
以及他心爱的哈雷戴维森摩托车。杰克鼓励他带上哈雷，告诉斯科特牧场周围的地区非常漂亮，非常适合骑摩托车。11月初，斯科特把拖车挂在皮卡车后面，前往俄亥俄州。11月6日星期日早上，斯科特在玛丽埃塔镇一家叫Shoney's的餐馆停了下来。他计划在那里与杰克共进早餐，然后前往他将居住和工作的牧场。当斯科特进入餐馆时，杰克已经和一个看起来十几岁的高个子年轻人在一起等着了。杰克介绍说那个男孩是他的侄子。
Jack was tall too, with a solid build. He was middle-aged, perhaps around 51 or 52, with wispy salt and pepper hair that was longer at the back. He had a moustache, and it looked like he'd recently shaved his beard. He'd missed a couple of spots where patches of facial hair remained. Jack was chatty over breakfast, asking Scott what belongs? he'd packed for his new life. His nephew didn't say much, instead focusing on his food. After they finished eating, they prepared to go to the ranch. Jack explained that the small road
杰克也很高，身材结实。他中年，大约51或52岁，留着稀疏的灰白头发，后脑勺的头发较长。他留着胡子，看起来像是刚刮过胡子。他漏掉了一些地方，还有几块胡茬残留。杰克在早餐时很健谈，问斯科特带了什么东西去开始他的新生活。他的侄子没怎么说话，而是专注于他的食物。吃完饭后，他们准备去牧场。杰克解释说那条小路
leading to the ranch was damaged and needed to be repaired before Scott could drive his truck on it. Scott was to leave his vehicle in a parking lot in the town of Caldwell for the time being, while Jack showed him the ropes. Scott got in the back seat of Jack's white Buick LaSaber, while Jack took the passenger seat and his nephew drove. Jack chatted while his nephew kept his eyes on the road, telling Scott about foods he liked, the church he preached at, and his ex-wife. The surrounding landscape became increasingly rural.
通往牧场的那条路损坏了，在斯科特能开车上去之前需要修理。斯科特暂时把车停在考德威尔镇的一个停车场，而杰克带他熟悉环境。斯科特坐进了杰克那辆白色别克LeSabre的后座，杰克坐在副驾驶座，他的侄子开车。杰克在聊天时，他的侄子目不转睛地盯着路，杰克告诉斯科特他喜欢的食物、他传教的教堂以及他的前妻。周围的景观变得越来越乡村化。
Soon enough, they were driving on a dirt road, and Scott had no signal on his cell phone. After driving for about 15 minutes, they reached a heavily wooded area, and Jack asked his nephew to pull over, saying, quote, Drop us off where we got that deer at last time. Jack told Scott he'd left some equipment they needed to repair the road down a hill near a creek, and he needed Scott's help to get it. The two men hopped out of the car, while the teenager did a U-turn,
很快，他们行驶在一条土路上，斯科特的手机没有信号。开了大约15分钟后，他们到达了一个树木茂密的地区，杰克让他的侄子靠边停车，说：“把我们放在上次我们抓到那头鹿的地方。”杰克告诉斯科特，他把修理道路所需的一些设备留在了小溪附近的山下，他需要斯科特的帮助去拿。两个男人跳下车，而那个少年掉了个头，
then headed off again. Scott followed Jack down the hill into the woods. Soon they reached the creek, but Scott didn't see any equipment. Jack appeared to be lost and soon gave up, telling Scott, Forget this, let's turn around and take the roadway. Scott turned and began to retrace his steps, this time walking in front of Jack. Then he heard a click behind him, followed by the word, fuck. Scott thought the click sounded like a gun misfiring.
然后又开走了。斯科特跟着杰克下山进入树林。很快他们到达了小溪，但斯科特没有看到任何设备。杰克似乎迷路了，很快就放弃了，告诉斯科特：“算了，我们回去走大路吧。”斯科特转身开始原路返回，这次走在杰克前面。然后他听到身后传来一声咔哒声，接着是一个词：“他妈的”。斯科特以为那咔哒声听起来像枪支走火。
He spun around and saw Jack, his eyes cold, aiming a revolver directly at him. Jack pulled the trigger again, right as Scott impulsively reached out and tried to grab the weapon. The bullet hit Scott in his right elbow. He began to run, the black leather baseball cap he was wearing falling off as he did so. He raced deeper into the woods, with the Jack in hot pursuit, firing at Scott again and again. Scott heard four gunshots, but none of them hit him. He ran until he couldn't go on anymore. It appeared that he'd lost to Jack.
他猛地转过身，看到杰克眼神冰冷，正用左轮手枪直接瞄准他。杰克再次扣动扳机，就在斯科特本能地伸手试图抓住武器时。子弹击中了斯科特的右肘。他开始奔跑，他戴的黑色皮质棒球帽在他奔跑时掉了下来。他向树林深处跑去，杰克紧追不舍，一次又一次地向斯科特开枪。斯科特听到了四声枪响，但都没有击中他。他一直跑，直到跑不动为止。看起来他已经甩掉了杰克。
Scott found a ravine and decided to hide there. As he sat low in the ravine, he heard a car passing back and forth on the nearby road. He had no doubt it was Jack looking for him. Scott was bleeding heavily, but he continued to hide. As the day drew on, Scott grew cold and hungry, yet was too scared to emerge in case his attacker was waiting for him. Finally, after about seven hours had passed, he knew he needed to move, if he wanted to live. Knight had fallen, and Scott walked several miles in the dark before coming across a farmhouse.
斯科特发现了一个沟壑，决定躲在那里。当他低身坐在沟壑里时，他听到一辆车在附近的路上一遍又一遍地经过。他毫不怀疑那是杰克在找他。斯科特流血严重，但他继续躲藏。随着白天过去，斯科特感到寒冷和饥饿，但太害怕了，不敢出来，生怕袭击者在等他。最后，在七个小时过去后，他知道如果想活命，他就必须移动。夜幕降临，斯科特在黑暗中走了几英里，才遇到一户农家。
He approached the house, terrified that it might belong to Jack. Knowing he had no other option, he knocked on the door. It was answered by a young boy who was there visiting his grandmother. He alerted his uncle, 37-year-old Jeff Shockling, who came to the door and called. called 911. As they waited for the police to arrive, Scott told Jeff that he'd been attacked by a man who'd offered him a job. Scott believed that the man intended to rob him.
他走近房子，害怕这可能是杰克的家。知道别无选择，他敲了敲门。开门的是一个正在探望祖母的小男孩。他叫醒了他的叔叔，37岁的杰夫·肖克林，他走到门口并拨打了911。在等待警察到达时，斯科特告诉杰夫他被一个给他提供工作的人袭击了。斯科特认为那个人打算抢劫他。
After all, he'd known that all of his most prized possessions, including his Harley Davidson, were piled up in a trailer attached to Scott's truck. The county's sheriff, Stephen Hannam, arrived about 15 minutes later. and Scott repeated his story. But Sheriff Hannam was doubtful of Scott's claims. For starters, Scott said he'd been hired to work on a 688-acre cattle ranch, but there were no ranches even remotely close to that size in Noble County. There were plenty of large rural stretches of land,
毕竟，他知道他所有最珍贵的财物，包括他的哈雷戴维森，都堆在挂在斯科特卡车后面的拖车里。县治安官斯蒂芬·汉纳姆（Stephen Hannam）大约15分钟后到达，斯科特重复了他的故事。但汉纳姆治安官对斯科特的说法表示怀疑。首先，斯科特说他被雇佣去一个688英亩的养牛场工作，但诺布尔县（Noble County）根本没有那么大的牧场。那里有很多大片的农村土地，
but they mostly belonged to mining companies. The sheriff was also slightly suspicious of Scott Davis himself. His long hair, scruffy beard and denim jacket, combined with references to his Harley Davidson, all pointed to him being a biker. Maybe he'd gotten caught up in a drug deal that had gone awry. While Scott was taken to hospital in an ambulance, investigators began following up on his claim.
但它们大多属于矿业公司。治安官对斯科特·戴维斯本人也有些怀疑。他长长的头发、邋遢的胡子和牛仔夹克，加上他提到的哈雷戴维森，都表明他是个骑手。也许他卷入了一场出了问题的毒品交易。当斯科特被救护车送往医院时，调查人员开始跟进他的说法。
They called some local informants to see if they knew anything about the case. They didn't. Investigators then, went out to the Caudwell parking lot where Scott said he'd left his truck and trailer. Both were still there, exactly as he'd described. On the dashboard of the truck were printouts of the emails Scott had exchanged with his prospective employer, Jack. All the details were pointing to his story, being true. Based on the detailed descriptions of Jack and his nephew that Scott had provided,
他们打电话给一些当地线人，看看他们是否知道这个案子的任何情况。他们不知道。调查人员随后去了考德威尔的停车场，斯科特说他把卡车和拖车留在了那里。两者都在那里，和他描述的一模一样。卡车的仪表盘上放着斯科特与他未来的雇主杰克交换的电子邮件打印件。所有的细节都指向他的故事是真实的。根据斯科特提供的关于杰克和他侄子的详细描述，
Sheriff Hannam wondered if the culprits could be a father and son who were known as Country and County. Country, whose real name was Jerry Hood Senior, lived on a farmhouse with his wife in the rural area Scott had detailed. The sheriff headed out to Country Hood's property. About half a mile from his residence, there was some heavy equipment by the road that Scott had described seeing. Sheriff Hannam decided to visit Hood's wife Lois at the tavern where she worked to see if she could shed any further light on the matter. Lois explained that her husband had been in hospital for the past two months after he slipped and hit his head.
汉纳姆治安官想知道罪犯是否是一对被称为“Country”和“County”的父子。Country，真名叫杰里·胡德（Jerry Hood Senior），和他的妻子住在他描述的农村地区的一处农舍里。治安官前往Country Hood的房产。在他住所大约半英里外，有一些斯科特描述看到的重型设备。汉纳姆治安官决定去Country Hood的妻子洛伊丝（Lois）工作的酒馆，看看她是否能提供更多线索。洛伊丝解释说，她的丈夫在两个月前滑倒撞到头后一直住院。
The sheriff also spoke with Hood's son, County. Scott had described Jack as having a moustache with a recently shaved beard, yet County Hood had a full beard. It was clear that the two men who'd first come to the sheriff's minds were both innocent. Investigators contacted the Shoney's diner where Scott Davis had met Jack and his nephew and obtained security footage from inside the venue. It showed the two men who had met up with Scott standing and waiting for a table, their faces visible.
治安官还与Hood的儿子County谈了话。斯科特描述杰克留着胡子，最近刮了胡子，但County Hood留着满脸胡子。很明显，治安官首先想到的两个男人都是无辜的。调查人员联系了斯科特·戴维斯与杰克和他侄子见面的Shoney's餐馆，并获得了场馆内的监控录像。录像显示，与斯科特见面的两个男人站在那里等位，他们的脸清晰可见。
The older man wore a dark jacket and a black baseball cap with a logo on the front. The teenager wore a light-coloured button-down shirt and stood with his arms crossed. On Tuesday, November 8, two days after Scott was attacked, investigators located the baseball cap that Scott had lost while fleeing from Jack. It was lying in the shallows of a creek that intersected the dirt road Scott and Jack had walked along. The land there wasn't part of a ranch, but was owned by a coal company and sometimes left, to hunters. Investigators had identified the crime scene.
那个年长的男人穿着深色夹克，戴着一顶前面有标志的黑色棒球帽。那个少年穿着浅色纽扣衬衫，双臂交叉站着。11月8日星期二，即斯科特遇袭两天后，调查人员找到了斯科特在逃离杰克时丢失的棒球帽。它躺在斯科特和杰克走过的土路交叉的一条小溪的浅滩里。那里的土地不属于牧场，而是属于一家煤炭公司，有时留给猎人使用。调查人员确定了犯罪现场。
The investigation was progressing well, but without urgency. That suddenly changed on the evening of Friday, November 11, when the sheriff's office received a call from a woman named Deborah Bruce. Deborah had been trawling the website of Noble County's local newspaper, looking for clues about her missing twin brother, David Pawley, when she came across an article detailing Scott Davis's ordeal. The article explained how Scott had been lured in with the promise of a job on a 68-acre cattle ranch, exactly like the job David had set out for three weeks earlier before disappearing completely.
调查进展顺利，但并不紧迫。这种情况在11月11日星期五晚上发生了突然变化，当时治安官办公室接到了一个名叫黛博拉·布鲁斯（Deborah Bruce）的女人的电话。黛博拉一直在浏览诺布尔县当地报纸的网站，寻找关于她失踪的双胞胎哥哥大卫·保利的线索，这时她看到了一篇详细描述斯科特·戴维斯遭遇的文章。文章解释了斯科特是如何被诱骗去一个68英亩的养牛场工作的，这与大卫在三周前失踪前出发去的工作完全一样。
Realising this couldn't be a coincidence, Deborah immediately called the Noble County Sheriff's Office to tell them about her brother and how he'd replied to the same Craigslist ad as Scott. Davis. The team immediately fast-tracked the investigation. It looked as though they might have an actual murder to solve, as well as an attempted one. On Monday, November 14, a search team composed of local law enforcement and FBI agents went back to the site in the woods where Scott's baseball cap was found. They spanned out from the creek bed and carefully scoured the area. About 100 to 150 feet from the spot where the hat was recovered, searches discovered an empty hole that appeared to have been dug by hand. It was a couple of feet deep and approximately 80 inches long.
意识到这不可能是巧合，黛博拉立即打电话给诺布尔县治安官办公室，告诉他们关于她哥哥的事，以及他是如何回复与斯科特·戴维斯相同的Craigslist广告的。团队立即加快了调查速度。看起来他们可能要解决一起真正的谋杀案，以及一起未遂谋杀案。11月14日星期一，由当地执法部门和联邦调查局特工组成的搜查队回到了树林里发现斯科特棒球帽的地方。他们从溪床散开，仔细搜查了该地区。在发现帽子的地点约100到150英尺处，搜查人员发现了一个看起来是手工挖掘的空洞。它有几英尺深，大约80英寸长。
The first impression of the investigators present was that the hole was actually an intended grave. The next day, cadaver dogs were dispatched to the same location. It was pouring rain and coyotes could be heard howling in the distance. Several hours before nightfall, one of the dogs alerted at a patch of disturbed soil about 80 feet from the empty grave. The patch was at the bottom of a hillside and had several tree branches lying on top. Investigators began digging at the wet soil with their hands. The heavy downpour of rain had led to puddles dotting the ground.
在场调查人员的第一印象是，这个洞实际上是一个预定的坟墓。第二天，搜尸犬被派往同一地点。当时下着倾盆大雨，远处可以听到土狼的嚎叫声。在夜幕降临前几个小时，其中一只狗在距离空坟墓约80英尺处的一块被扰动的土壤上发出了警报。这块地位于山坡底部，上面躺着几根树枝。调查人员开始用手挖掘潮湿的土壤。大雨导致地面上布满了水坑。
As they clawed at the dirt, blood, blood, began bubbling up from the ground into the muddy water. Then a foot wearing a sock emerged. Investigators formally excavated the area and two feet beneath the surface, they uncovered the body of a man lying face down. He had been shot in the back of the head with either a 32 or 38 caliber firearm. The man was almost completely naked, but tied around one of his wrists was a black leather bracelet with a silver clasp. A detective called Deborah Bruce and described the bracelet to her.
当他们抓挠泥土时，血开始从地下冒出来，进入泥水中。然后一只穿着袜子的脚露了出来。调查人员正式挖掘了该区域，在表面下方两英尺处，他们发现了一具面朝下躺着的男人的尸体。他的后脑勺被32或38口径的枪支击中。这名男子几乎完全赤裸，但他的手腕上系着一个带有银扣的黑色皮手链。一名侦探给黛博拉·布鲁斯打了电话，向她描述了手链。
She began to shake. She knew that the bracelet belonged to her twin brother. The man lying in the muddy grave was David Pawley. In a bid to track down the mysterious Jack, investigators requested assistance from an FBI cyber crimes expert. Using Jack's job ad, they were able to obtain information from Craigslist that led to the user's IP address. In turn, this led to a physical address of a house in the Ohio City of Akron. Detectives obtained a search warrant and made the 100-mile journey north to visit the home.
她开始颤抖。她知道那个手链属于她的双胞胎哥哥。躺在泥泞坟墓里的男人是大卫·保利。为了追踪神秘的杰克，调查人员请求联邦调查局网络犯罪专家的协助。利用杰克的招聘广告，他们能够从Craigslist获得信息，从而找到了用户的IP地址。反过来，这导致了俄亥俄州阿克伦（Akron）市一所房子的实际地址。侦探们获得了搜查令，并向北行驶了100英里去探访这所房子。
When they knocked on the front door, it was answered by the homeowner, a man named Joe Bayes. Joe said he lived at the house with his wife and a young child. He insisted that he hadn't posted anything on Craig's list and he didn't know anyone named Jack. However, when detectives showed Joe a photo of the man they were looking for, taken from the CCTV footage at Shoney's diner, Joe recognized him right away. Joe identified the man as Ralph Geiger, who went by the nickname Dirk. Joe had turned his basement into an apartment which Dutch had started renting in either August or
当他们敲前门时，开门的是房主，一个名叫乔·贝斯（Joe Bayes）的男人。乔说他和妻子以及一个年幼的孩子住在这所房子里。他坚称他没有在Craigslist上发布任何东西，也不认识叫杰克的人。然而，当侦探们向乔展示他们正在寻找的男人的照片（取自Shoney's餐馆的监控录像）时，乔立刻认出了他。乔认出那个人是拉尔夫·盖格（Ralph Geiger），绰号“Dirk”。乔把他的地下室改造成了一间公寓，Dirk在8月或
September for 100 a month. However, he'd moved out at the end of October, just two weeks prior. Joe described Dutch as a real nice guy and a good housemate. He was a churchgoer and hadn't been prone to drinking, smoking or swearing. During his time at the house, he was given access to to Joe's computer and internet connection. The detectives asked Joe if there was anything in the house that had belonged to Dutch. Joe said yes. He'd traded his computer with the Dutch in exchange for some boxes of miscellaneous items. He gave the boxes to detectives.
9月开始以每月100美元的价格租用。然而，他在10月底，也就是两周前搬走了。乔形容Dirk是一个非常好的人，一个好室友。他是个去教堂的人，不喝酒、不抽烟、不骂人。在他住在那里的期间，他可以使用乔的电脑和互联网连接。侦探们问乔房子里是否有属于Dirk的东西。乔说是的。他用他的电脑和Dirk交换了一些杂物箱。他把箱子交给了侦探。
Amongst the contents were personal items belonging to David Paulie. Detectives searched the basement apartment and found a few. possessions Dutch had left behind, including prescription pill bottles with the name Ralph Geiger printed on them. Investigators were just as eager to track down the teenager that had accompanied their prime suspect. Jack had told Scott Davis that the boy's name was Brogan. Investigators were able to identify the teen as 16-year-old Brogan Rafferty, who was a student at Stowe-Munrow Falls High School, just outside of Akron. On Wednesday, November 16, the day after the discovery of David Pauli's body, an FBI agent
内容物中包括属于大卫·保利的个人物品。侦探们搜查了地下室公寓，发现了一些Dirk留下的财物，包括上面印有“拉尔夫·盖格”名字的处方药瓶。调查人员同样急于追踪陪伴他们主要嫌疑人的少年。杰克曾告诉斯科特·戴维斯那个男孩的名字叫布罗根（Brogan）。调查人员能够确定那个少年是16岁的布罗根·拉弗蒂（Brogan Rafferty），他是阿克伦郊外斯托-门罗福尔斯高中（Stowe-Munrow Falls High School）的学生。11月16日星期三，即发现大卫·保利尸体的第二天，一名联邦调查局特工
and a detective went to Brogan's high school and spoke with him in the principal's office. Brogan appeared completely calm. He admitted to having met with Scott Davis at Shoney's diner, but denied any knowledge of Scott being shot. He also did not. He also did not. He also denied knowing anything about what had happened to David Paulie. Brogan said he didn't want to speak further without an attorney, and he was permitted to leave. However, a sheriff's deputy monitored him at the school for the remainder of the day to ensure he didn't attempt to flee. Meanwhile, a group of investigators headed to the Raffity residents to conduct a search of the home. In Brogan's bedroom, they uncovered a briefcase contained
和一名侦探去了布罗根的高中，并在校长办公室与他谈话。布罗根看起来非常冷静。他承认在Shoney's餐馆见过斯科特·戴维斯，但否认知道斯科特被枪击的事。他也不。他也不。他还否认知道大卫·保利发生了什么事。布罗根说他不想在没有律师的情况下进一步交谈，他被允许离开。然而，一名治安官副手在学校剩余的时间里监视他，以确保他没有试图逃跑。与此同时，一组调查人员前往拉弗蒂的住所对房子进行搜查。在布罗根的卧室里，他们发现了一个公文包，里面装有
a sword-off shotgun, a 22-gauge semi-automatic pistol, a knife, bullets, and several shotgun shells. On Brogan's computer was a word document dated Tuesday, August 16, 2011, several months before David Pawley and Scott Davis had been attacked. The document appeared to be a poem that Brogan had written. It read in part, We took him out to the woods on a humid summer's night. I walked in front of them. They were going back to the car.
一把锯短的猎枪、一把22口径半自动手枪、一把刀、子弹和几枚猎枪弹壳。在布罗根的电脑上有一个Word文档，日期是2011年8月16日星期二，在大卫·保利和斯科特·戴维斯遇袭前几个月。该文档似乎是布罗根写的一首诗。部分内容写道：“我们在一个潮湿的夏夜把他带到树林里。我走在他们前面。他们正要回车里。”
I didn't turn around. The loud crack echoed and I didn't hear the thud. The two of us went back to the car for the shovels. I dug the hole. We put him in with difficulty. They call them stiffs for a reason. When I got home, took a shower hotter than hell itself. Prayed like hell that night.
“我没有回头。巨大的响声回荡着，我没有听到重击声。我们两个回到车里拿铲子。我挖了洞。我们费力地把他放进去。他们称他们为‘僵尸’是有原因的。当我回到家，洗了个热得要命的澡。那天晚上祈祷得要命。”
Later that evening, police returned to Brogan's home and placed him under arrest. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. After being taken into custody, Brogan Rafferty initially said little, but a week after his arrest, he was persuaded to talk. Brogan's childhood hadn't been easy. His mother struggled with a drug addiction and had lost custody of Brogan and her three other
那天晚上晚些时候，警察回到布罗根家并将他逮捕。CaseFile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。在被拘留后，布罗根·拉弗蒂最初说得很少，但在被捕一周后，他说服了自己开口。布罗根的童年并不容易。他的母亲与毒瘾作斗争，并失去了布罗根和她另外三个
children. Brogan lived with his father, Michael, who worked an early shift at a machine shop. Michael did his best, but Brogan had to be somewhat self-sufficient from a very young age, getting ready for school alone at just five years old and walking to the bus stop by himself every day. When Brogan was eight years old, he told his father he wanted to attend church on Sundays. Michael wasn't keen to wake up so early on the weekend, but he gave Brogan permission to attend church with a good friend of his named Richard Beasley. Beasley was a bit of a rough character and Michael knew him to be something of a, quote, scam artist. But Michael had never seen him be angry or aggressive and thought he was a safe person for his son to spend time with.
孩子的监护权。布罗根和他的父亲迈克尔（Michael）住在一起，迈克尔在一家机械厂上早班。迈克尔尽了最大努力，但布罗根从很小的时候起就必须在某种程度上自力更生，五岁时就独自准备上学，每天独自走到公交车站。当布罗根八岁时，他告诉父亲他想在星期天去教堂。迈克尔不想在周末起得那么早，但他允许布罗根和一个名叫理查德·比斯利（Richard Beasley）的好朋友一起去教堂。比斯利是一个有点粗鲁的角色，迈克尔知道他有点像个“骗子”。但迈克尔从未见过他生气或咄咄逼人，认为他是一个让儿子相处安全的成年人。
Brogan began attending church with Beasley every week and came to enjoy spending time with the older man. Unlike his own father who could be impatient and quick-tempered, Beasily was calm with a hearty laugh. Sometimes Brogan felt certain that Richard Beasley was actually Santa Claus. He physically resembled the legendary figure and carried lollies in his pocket that he would share with Brogan. Sometimes Brogan's half-sister would join the pair of church, along with Beasley's own daughter. After the sermons ended, Beasley would take them out to McDonald's or get them donuts and offer advice on how important it was to stay in school and avoid drugs. Beasley had his own checkered past that gave these lessons credibility. He'd been a bright child with a charismatic personality, but he'd grown up in an abusive household.
布罗根开始每周和比斯利一起去教堂，并开始喜欢和这个年长的男人在一起。与他自己可能急躁且脾气暴躁的父亲不同，比斯利很冷静，笑声爽朗。有时布罗根确信理查德·比斯利实际上就是圣诞老人。他在外表上像那个传奇人物，口袋里装着糖果，会和布罗根分享。有时布罗根同父异母的妹妹会和比斯利自己的女儿一起加入他们去教堂。布道结束后，比斯利会带他们去麦当劳或买甜甜圈，并就保持学业和远离毒品的重要性提供建议。比斯利有他自己坎坷的过去，这让这些教训具有了可信度。他曾经是一个聪明、性格有魅力的孩子，但他是在一个虐待家庭中长大的。
Eager to leave his Ohio hometown once he was an adult, he relocated to Texas, where he began committing crimes, specifically burglary. He wound up in prison in the 1980s and moved back to Akron after he was released in 1990. A motorcycle enthusiast, he met his future wife at a biker event and the couple soon had a daughter. While he kept up a respectable front, he was burglarising homes behind his family's back while also illegally dealing weapons. In 1996, Beasley was arrested again and sentenced to seven years. His wife divorced him, but Beasley maintained a relationship. He was arrested. relationship with his daughter. It was during this incarceration that Beasley found God and
成年后，他急于离开俄亥俄州的家乡，于是搬到了德克萨斯州，在那里他开始犯罪，主要是入室盗窃。他在20世纪80年代入狱，1990年获释后搬回了阿克伦。作为一名摩托车爱好者，他在一次骑行活动中遇到了未来的妻子，两人很快有了一个女儿。虽然他一直保持着体面的外表，但却在家人背后进行入室盗窃，同时还非法贩卖武器。1996年，比斯利再次被捕，被判处七年监禁。他的妻子与他离婚，但比斯利仍与女儿保持着联系。他被捕了。与女儿的关系。正是在这次监禁期间，比斯利找到了上帝，并
became a born-again Christian. After his release, he began spending lots of time at an Akron church known as the chapel. His newfound faith prompted him to attend Bible study classes and volunteer at a soup kitchen. Beasley was an example of how religion could reform a person. When he gifted Broughan Raffertya Bible, he wrote a message inside that read, The Bible is the key to peace of mind and a roadmap to salvation. Over the course of almost a decade, Richard Beasley became like an uncle to Brogan. But there was another side to him beneath the clean living church-going exterior. In the mid-2000s, he was in a car accident that left him with several injuries.
成为了一名重生的基督徒。获释后，他开始花大量时间在阿克伦一家名为“礼拜堂”的教堂。他新获得的信仰促使他参加圣经学习班，并在施粥处做志愿者。比斯利成为了宗教如何改造一个人的典范。当他送给布罗根·拉弗蒂一本圣经时，他在里面写道：“圣经是心灵平静的钥匙，也是通往救赎的路线图。”在近十年的时间里，理查德·比斯利对布罗根来说就像叔叔一样。但在他那干净、虔诚的教堂外表下，还有另一面。2000年代中期，他遭遇了一场车祸，导致多处受伤。
He began taking opiates for neck and back pain, stopped working consistently and withdrew from his family. At the same time, his relationship with Brogan Rafferty remained strong. Using money he'd received from a settlement relating to his car accident, Beasley founded a halfway house. It was ostensibly a place where those overcoming substance addiction or reintegrating with society after serving time could get back on their feet. Beasley told people he wanted to help a drug users, sex workers, and teenage runaways. At night, he drove around Akron, his eyes peeled for people who needed assistance. He preached the Bible to his halfway house residence and helped those with court appearances by vouching on their behalf. These good deeds led to him being nicknamed Chaplain Rich. In reality,
他开始服用阿片类药物来缓解颈部和背部疼痛，不再稳定工作，并疏远了家人。与此同时，他与布罗根·拉弗蒂的关系依然稳固。利用车祸赔偿金，比斯利创办了一家收容所。表面上，这是一个让那些克服药物成瘾或服刑后重新融入社会的人能够重新站起来的地方。比斯利告诉人们，他想帮助吸毒者、性工作者和离家出走的青少年。晚上，他开车在阿克伦四处转悠，寻找需要帮助的人。他向收容所的居民传教，并通过为那些有出庭需求的人作担保来帮助他们。这些善举使他获得了“里奇牧师”的绰号。实际上，
Beasley took advantage of the people who moved into his halfway house. At one stage, there were five or six sex workers living there, and Beasley began acting as their pimp. He purchased cell phones for them, drove them to meet clients, and posted ads for them online. While he was never physically violent towards these women, he exerted a lot of control over them. If any ever spoke of wanting to leave,
比斯利利用了搬进他收容所的人。有一段时间，那里住着五六名性工作者，比斯利开始充当她们的皮条客。他为她们购买手机，开车送她们去见客户，并在网上为她们发布广告。虽然他从未对这些女性进行过身体暴力，但他对她们实施了极大的控制。如果有人提到想离开，
Beasley fought to keep them there by giving them drugs. He also dealt drugs as a way to make cash. In February of 2011, Beasley was arrested on drug charges. As this was in violation of his parole, he was held on remand in the county jail. It turned out that some of the women Beasley had abused had gone to the police, and for the past two years, prosecutors had been building a case against him for pimping sex workers at his halfway house. If convicted, he faced spending the rest of his life in prison. Five months later, in July 2011, he was released on bail, but subsequently failed to check in with authorities, which led to a warrant being issued for his arrest. Richard Beasley was
比斯利就会通过给她们毒品来强迫她们留下来。他还通过贩毒来赚钱。2011年2月，比斯利因毒品指控被捕。由于这违反了他的假释规定，他被关押在县监狱候审。事实证明，一些被比斯利虐待过的女性已经报了警，过去两年来，检察官一直在收集他利用收容所拉皮条的证据。如果罪名成立，他将面临余生在监狱中度过的命运。五个月后，即2011年7月，他获准保释，但随后未能向当局报到，导致警方对他发出了逮捕令。理查德·比斯利
officially fleeing from the law. By this point, he'd isolated broken raffity from other loved ones and made him entirely dependent on Beasley's affection and approval. Beasley had gone from being a mentor to the teenager to a father figure who Brogan's life revolved around. Meeting up with Beasley and helping him out with whatever he asked was Brogan's primary focus. The pair spoke every other day and spent time together several times a week. In early August 2011, Beasley. confided in Brogan that he was on the run from the law.
正式开始逃避法律制裁。此时，他已将布罗根·拉弗蒂与亲人隔绝，使他完全依赖比斯利的关爱和认可。比斯利从这位青少年的导师变成了布罗根生活围绕的核心人物。与比斯利见面并帮他处理任何要求成了布罗根的首要任务。两人每隔一天就会交谈，每周还会聚在一起几次。2011年8月初，比斯利向布罗根吐露，他正在躲避法律制裁。
There was a warrant out for his arrest and he was being framed for a crime he didn't commit. Beasley didn't want to go back to prison and said he needed Brogan's help to survive. Brogan was upset to hear that his mentor was being unfairly persecuted by law enforcement and agreed to help where he could. Beasley decided he needed a whole new identity. entity, and he planned to obtain one by any means necessary. He began lurking around a homeless shelter, keeping an eye out for middle-aged men who bore a resemblance to him. Soon, he honed in on one particular individual who seemed to fit the bill, a man named Ralph Geiger. At 56 years old,
他身上有逮捕令，并声称自己因未犯下的罪行而被陷害。比斯利不想回到监狱，并说他需要布罗根的帮助才能生存。布罗根听到他的导师受到执法部门的不公正迫害感到很难过，并同意尽其所能提供帮助。比斯利决定他需要一个全新的身份，并计划不惜一切代价获得一个。他开始在一家无家可归者收容所附近徘徊，留意那些与他长相相似的中年男子。很快，他锁定了一个似乎符合条件的人，一个名叫拉尔夫·盖格的男子。56岁时，
Ralph Geiger was doing it tough. He once had a successful construction business, but he'd been hit hard by the recession, and by August 2011, he was unhoused and staying at a shelter in Akron. Eager to get back on his feet, Ralph felt a sense of renewed hope when he met Richard Beasley and was offered a caretaker position on his large cattle ranch. Ralph had grown up on a farm and would be in his element in such a role. He told staff at the shelter about his new job, as well as a close friend. named Summer Rowley. Although Ralph and Summer spoke daily,
拉尔夫·盖格的日子过得很艰难。他曾经拥有一家成功的建筑公司，但受到经济衰退的沉重打击，到2011年8月，他已无家可归，住在阿克伦的一家收容所里。渴望重新站起来的拉尔夫在遇到理查德·比斯利并被提供一份大型养牛场的看管工作时，感到了一丝重燃的希望。拉尔夫在农场长大，在这样的岗位上会如鱼得水。他告诉收容所的工作人员以及一位名叫萨默·罗利的密友关于他的新工作。虽然拉尔夫和萨默每天都通话，
he warned her that he wouldn't have cell phone reception on the ranch and therefore wouldn't be in contact as much. On the night of Monday, August 8, 2011, Ralph checked into a best western motel in Caldwell, the town Beasley said was near his ranch. No one ever heard from him again. According to Brogan Rafferty, He and Beasley had met up with Ralph Geiger on Tuesday, August 9.
但他警告她说，牧场没有手机信号，因此联系不会那么频繁。2011年8月8日星期一晚上，拉尔夫在考德威尔的一家最佳西方汽车旅馆办理了入住，比斯利说那个镇就在他的牧场附近。此后，再也没有人收到过他的消息。据布罗根·拉弗蒂说，他和比斯利在8月9日星期二与拉尔夫·盖格见了面。
With Brogan acting as Beasley's driver, they took him out to the same wooded area where they later took David Paulie and Scott Davis. They all got out of the car and Beasley used a pistol to shoot Ralph in the back of the head. Brogan then helped him bury the body nearby. He later said that he felt like he had ice in his veins and was in a stable. of shock. Afterwards, Beasley died his white-haired dark so it looked like Ralph's, and applied for multiple jobs under Ralph's name. He also moved into Joe Bayes' house, giving him Ralph's name instead of his own. On Monday, September 19, Beasley opened a bank account as Ralph Geiger. The following day, he used Ralph's name to visit a doctor and obtain prescription painkillers.
在布罗根担任比斯利司机的情况下，他们把他带到了后来带大卫·保利和斯科特·戴维斯去的同一个树林地区。他们都下了车，比斯利用手枪射击了拉尔夫的后脑勺。布罗根随后帮他在附近掩埋了尸体。他后来表示，他感觉血液都结冰了，处于一种休克状态。事后，比斯利把他的白发染黑，看起来像拉尔夫，并以拉尔夫的名义申请了多份工作。他还搬进了乔·贝斯的房子，给了他拉尔夫的名字而不是他自己的。9月19日星期一，比斯利以拉尔夫·盖格的名义开设了一个银行账户。第二天，他用拉尔夫的名字去看医生并获得了处方止痛药。
While Beasley got on with his new life, Brogan said that he was terrified. Knowing that the man he'd built his life around was a killer, he was scared that he or someone he loved might be next. Brogan claimed that Beasley had warned him, I know where your mother lives, I know where your sister lives. In September 2011, Richard Beasley was hired to be a quality inspector, at a manufacturing plant, but due to his chronic back pain, he found the work difficult.
当比斯利开始他的新生活时，布罗根说他感到非常恐惧。知道他生活围绕的那个男人是个杀人犯，他害怕自己或他所爱的人可能是下一个。布罗根声称比斯利曾警告他：“我知道你母亲住在哪里，我知道你妹妹住在哪里。”2011年9月，理查德·比斯利被聘为一家制造厂的质量检查员，但由于长期的背痛，他觉得工作很吃力。
As his first attempt at killing someone for personal gain had gone off without a hitch, he decided to do it again. This time, instead of just stealing his victim's identity, he would also rob them for financial gain. Richard Beasley had learned about Craig's List from his daughter, who had helped him catch up on all things technology after his release from prison. She'd helped him set up an account so he could sell some old furniture. Armed with this knowledge, Beasley used the site to craft a job ad, offering an idyllic lifestyle for someone down on their luck. He specified that older and single candidates were preferred, because he was hoping for victims with few personal ties. Beasley wanted people
由于他第一次为了个人利益杀人的尝试进行得非常顺利，他决定再做一次。这一次，他不仅要窃取受害者的身份，还要抢劫他们以获取经济利益。理查德·比斯利从女儿那里了解到了Craigslist网站，女儿在他出狱后帮他补习了所有科技知识。她帮他建立了一个账户，这样他就可以卖掉一些旧家具。有了这些知识，比斯利利用该网站制作了一则招聘广告，为那些运气不佳的人提供了一种田园诗般的生活方式。他特别说明优先考虑年长和单身的人，因为他希望受害者与外界的联系越少越好。比斯利想要那些
who could disappear without raising suspicion. It was also crucial that they have no criminal record so as to avoid any trouble with the police. Over 100 applications quickly flooded in, including responses from David Pawley and Scott Davis, who both emailed Beasley on the same day. Beasley weeded through them to find the right, quote, candidates. Any applications from...
可以消失而不引起怀疑的人。同样至关重要的是，他们不能有犯罪记录，以免引起警察的麻烦。100多份申请很快涌入，包括大卫·保利和斯科特·戴维斯的回复，他们都在同一天给比斯利发了电子邮件。比斯利从中筛选出合适的“候选人”。任何来自女性或有伴侣的男性的申请都被忽略并删除了。在初步筛选过程后，比斯利给潜在受害者打了电话进行面试，自称叫杰克。他利用这些电话进一步澄清细节，例如申请人的婚姻状况和任何可能的犯罪背景。他还打听了他们如果被录用打算带什么个人物品。并非所有面试者都进入了下一轮。10月，比斯利与一名叫丹尼尔的候选人见面，当面讨论这份工作。
women or from men with partners were ignored and deleted. After his initial screening process, Beasley called his potential victims for a telephone interview, claiming his name was Jack. He used these calls to clarify further details, such as the applicant's marital status and any possible criminal background. He also sussed out what personal belongings they intended to bring with them if hired. Not all of those interviewed made it through to the next round. In October, Beasley met with a candidate named Daniel to discuss the job in person.
丹尼尔获得了这个职位，并开始准备搬家。丹尼尔提到他会带一把手枪。比斯利起初说没问题，但后来改变了主意，告诉丹尼尔：“我是唯一有枪的人。”丹尼尔觉得这很可疑。他试图在诺布尔县审计员的网站上查找牧场的详细信息，但什么也没查到。
Daniel was offered the position and began preparing for the move. Daniel mentioned that he'd be bringing a pistol with him. Beasley initially said that was fine, but later changed his mind, telling Daniel, I am the only one with a gun. Daniel found this suspicious. He tried to find the ranch's details on the Noble County Auditor's website, but nothing came up.
感到担忧的丹尼尔告诉比斯利：“这说不通。”最后一根稻草是比斯利提出要购买丹尼尔的SUV和皮卡车。他说他会去取车，然后等丹尼尔到达牧场后再给他钱。
Concerned, Daniel told Beasley, quote, This ain't adding up. The final straw came when Beasley offered to buy Daniel's SUV and pickup truck. He said he'd pick them up and then give Daniel the money, once he arrived at the ranch.
丹尼尔不喜欢这个计划，对比斯利说：“如果有人在我去那里之前试图抢走我的车，然后等我到了那里，他们开枪打死我并抢走我的东西怎么办？”比斯利回答说：“你不该这么说。”随后，他给丹尼尔发了一封电子邮件，正式撤回了工作邀请。大约在同一时间，比斯利也在和另一个名叫乔治的男人交谈。
Daniel disliked this plan, saying to Beasley, What if somebody is trying to get my vehicles before I come down there, and then when I get down there, they shoot me and take my stuff? Beasley responded, You shouldn't have said that. He then sent Daniel an email formally rescinding the job offer. Around the same time, Beasley was. also talking to another man named George.
半退休并寻求一份轻松的工作来增加收入的乔治认为比斯利的广告听起来很理想。两人在美食广场见面讨论细节。面试进行得很顺利，直到乔治提到他几乎一生都参与武术。比斯利突然靠在椅背上。当乔治补充说他以前曾担任过保安时，比斯利收起了乔治的申请，
Semi-retired and seeking an easy job to supplement his income, George thought Beasley's ad sounded ideal. The two met at a food court to talk specifics. The interview was going well until George mentioned that he'd been involved with martial arts for almost his entire life. Beasley suddenly sat back in his chair. When George added, he was. that he'd previously worked as a security guard, Beasley put George's application away and
并突然结束了面试。乔治再也没有收到他的消息。大卫·保利是第一个成功的候选人。10月23日星期日清晨，在大卫预定在俄亥俄州与他们见面的几个小时前，理查德·比斯利再次寻求布罗根·拉弗蒂的帮助。他们买了一些短铲，开车前往拉尔夫·盖格被埋葬的大致区域。在比斯利的监督下，布罗根挖了一个坟墓。
abruptly ended the interview. George never heard from him again. David Paulie was the first successful candidate. Early on the morning of Sunday, October 23, mere hours before David was set to meet them in Ohio, Richard Beasley enlisted Brogan Rafferty's help once again. They bought some short. shovels and drove out to the general area where Ralph Geiger was buried. While Beasley supervised, Brogan dug a grave.
那天晚些时候，比斯利和布罗根前往他们约定与大卫见面的连锁餐厅。之后，两人开始了后来成为模式的行为。比斯利解释说去牧场的路坏了，所以他们必须先修好路，然后再回来取大卫的东西。布罗根随后开车将比斯利和大卫带到预先挖好的坟墓地点。布罗根靠边停车后，三人下了车，比斯利让布罗根和大卫跟着他上山。布罗根停下来小便，当他快结束时，听到了一声爆裂声。
Later that morning, Beasley and Brogan headed to the chain restaurant where they'd arranged to meet David. Afterwards, the duo embarked on what would become a pattern. Beasley explained that the road to the ranch was damaged, so they'd have to repair it before coming back for David's things. Brogan then drove Beasley and David out to the location of the pre-dug grave. After Brogan pulled over, the three got out of the car and Beasley asked Brogan and David to follow him up a hill. Brogan stopped to urinate and as he was finishing, he heard a cracking sound.
他转过身，看到大卫·保利脸朝下躺在地上，后脑勺中弹。布罗根埋葬大卫后，他和比斯利回到了停车场，那里停着大卫的蓝色道奇皮卡车和拖车。比斯利告诉熟人，他是通过竞拍一个储物单元并赢得了里面的东西才获得这些物品的。他把大卫的一些不太值钱的财物送了人，其他的则卖给了邻居和在跳蚤市场上出售。
He turned around and saw David poorly lying face down on the ground, having been able to be able to be. shot in the back of the head. After Brogan buried David, he and Beasley returned to the parking lot where David's Blue Dodge pickup truck and trailer were parked. Beasley told acquaintances that he'd acquired the items by bidding on a storage unit and winning its contents. He gave some of David's less valuable possessions away and sold others to neighbors and at flea markets.
这些东西都没有特别高的价值。大卫打包了一些火车模型、钓鱼工具箱、一台笔记本电脑和一些纳斯卡赛车的纪念品。比斯利还以1000美元的价格卖掉了大卫的卡车，并确保将大卫租来的拖车归还给了U-Haul设施。两周后，布罗根陪同比斯利与48岁的斯科特·戴维斯共进早餐。比斯利对这位候选人特别兴奋，因为他拥有一辆哈雷戴维森摩托车，比斯利曾告诉他带到俄亥俄州来。计划进行得和之前差不多，直到比斯利准备射杀斯科特时，他的左轮手枪卡壳了。
None of them were particularly high value. David had packed some model trains, fishing tackle boxes, a laptop and a bit of NASCAR memorabilia. Beasley also sold David's truck for $1,000 and made sure to return David's rented trailer to a U-Haul facility. Two weeks later, Brogan accompanied Beasley to a breakfast meeting with 48-year-old Scott Davis. Beasley was particularly excited about this candidate given that he owned a Harley Davidson, which Beasley had told him to bring to Ohio. The plan proceeded much like the previous one had, until Beasley went to shoot Scott and his revolver jammed.
听到武器哑火给了斯科特一个警示和逃跑的时间。比斯利冲回车里，布罗根正在那里等着，他告诉布罗根，如果他们看到斯科特，就必须开车撞倒他。两人开车来回寻找斯科特，但最终放弃了。在回家的路上，比斯利把车里的一些东西扔出窗外，这样如果斯科特向调查人员描述车内物品，他的车就不会那么容易被辨认出来。比斯利对他的计划落空感到非常沮丧。除了哈雷摩托车，斯科特还打包了一些高端电子产品，
Hearing the weapon misfire gave Scott a heads up and time to run away. Beasley raced back to the road where Brogan was waiting in his car and told the team that, If they saw Scott, they had to run him down. The pair drove back and forth looking for Scott, but eventually gave up. As they headed back home, Beasley threw some of the car's contents out the window, so that his vehicle would be less recognisable if Scott described its contents to investigators. Beasley was devastated that his plan had gone awry. As well as the Harley, Scott had packed some high-end electronics.
比斯利估计卖掉这些东西能赚大约3万美元。尽管警方很快就会调查这起谋杀未遂案，但他决定必须弥补意外的损失。理查德·比斯利开始寻找下一个受害者。47岁的蒂莫西·克恩正经历一段艰难时期。这位来自阿克伦的离异父亲曾是一名成功的俱乐部DJ，但在2001年被解雇。在随后的几年里，他一直在努力寻找稳定的工作。
and Beasley had estimated he'd make about $30,000 from selling it all. Despite the likelihood that police would soon be investigating the attempted murder, he decided he needed to make up for his unexpected loss. Richard Beasley went looking for another victim. 47-year-old Timothy Kern was going through a rough period. The divorced father of three from Akron had once been a successful club DJ. but had been let go in 2001. In the years that followed, he'd struggled to find consistent work.
他最终找到了一份街道清洁工的工作，但到2011年11月，他又失业了，没有固定住所。他在寻找新工作的同时，在朋友家借住和住在车里之间轮换。当他看到理查德·比斯利的Craigslist广告时，他形容这是一个“好提议，但很奇怪”，并没有像其他一些申请者那样立即表现出热情。这份工作意味着要搬到一个手机信号有限、
He eventually found a job as a street cleaner, but by November 2011, he was unemployed again and had no fixed address. He alternated between staying with friends and living out of his car while searching for a new job. When he came across Richard Beasley's Craigslist ad, he described it as a good offer, but strange, and wasn't as immediately enthusiastic as some of the other applicants. The job would mean relocating to an area with limited soul service
且离他儿子们很远的地方。虽然蒂莫西自14年前离婚后就没有和儿子们住在一起，但他仍然在他们的生活中扮演着重要的角色。他几乎每天每小时都会给他们打电话和发短信，并尽最大努力每天见到他们，即使他们的见面有时很短暂。2011年11月9日星期三，在袭击斯科特·戴维斯三天后，蒂莫西·克恩与理查德·比斯利进行了面试。他得到了这份工作，并于11月13日星期日出发去开始他的新职位。
and a significant distance from his sons. Although Timothy hadn't lived with his sons since his divorce 14 years prior, he remained a huge presence in their lives. He called and texted them almost every hour of every day, and did his best to see them every single day, even if their visits were sometimes fleeting. On Wednesday, November 9, 2011, three days after the attack on Scott Davis, Timothy Kern met Richard Beasley for a job interview. He got the job, and on Sunday, November 13, he set off to start his new position.
比斯利和布罗根第二天清晨在俄亥俄州坎顿的一个停车场接到了蒂莫西。比斯利开始询问蒂莫西带来的物品，此前他已确定蒂莫西拥有一台笔记本电脑和一台平板电视。蒂莫西说他只有一台旧电视和几个装满衣服和磁带的垃圾袋。他解释说他已经把笔记本电脑和更贵的电视给了他的儿子们。比斯利问蒂莫西身上带了多少现金，直到发第一份工资。
Beasley and Brogan picked Timothy up in a parking lot in Canton, Ohio, early the next morning. Beasley began asking Timothy about the items he'd brought with him, having previously established that Timothy owned a laptop and a flat-screen TV. Timothy said he just had an old television and some garbage bags filled with clothes and cassette tapes. He explained that he'd given the laptop and more expensive television to his sons. Beasley asked Timothy how much cash he had on him to get bought, until his first paycheck.
蒂莫西有些羞愧地说他只有5美元。布罗根后来告诉调查人员，他当时感到胃里一阵翻腾，意识到他们即将为了毫无价值的东西谋杀蒂莫西·克恩。但他们还是继续执行了计划。三人大约在早上6点乘坐比斯利的车出发时，天还没亮。这一次，布罗根开车把他们带到了阿克伦一家废弃商场后面的树林里，该商场在经济衰退期间倒闭了。由于关于斯科特·戴维斯遇袭案的新闻报道很多，之前的杀人地点太危险了。比斯利向蒂莫西解释说，他们早些时候在商场后面打松鼠，他丢了手表。
Somewhat cheapishly, Timothy said he only had $5. Brogan later told investigators that he felt a pit in his stomach at this point, realizing that they were about to murder Timothy Kern for absolutely nothing. But they still went ahead with the plan. It was still dark when the trio headed off in Beasley's vehicle at around 6am. This time, Brogan drove them to a wooded area behind a disused mall in Akron, which had gone out of business during the recession. The previous killing site was too dangerous, given there had been several news articles published about the attempt on Scott Davis's life. Beasley explained to Timothy that they'd been squirrel hunting behind the mall earlier and he'd lost his watch.
他想找回它，因为它有纪念意义。蒂莫西跟着比斯利走进树林，没过多久，布罗根就听到了一声枪响。他看过去，看到蒂莫西跪在地上，一只手捂着头的一侧。“你还好吗？”比斯利用关切的声音问道。随后他又开了四枪，击中蒂莫西的头部，将其杀害。他们把他的尸体埋在比斯利前一天晚上挖好的浅坑里。布罗根向调查人员描述了蒂莫西·克恩和拉尔夫·盖格的尸体被
He wanted to find it as it had sentimental value. Timothy followed Beasley into the woods, and not long after, Brogan heard a gunshot. He looked over and saw Timothy on his knees, a hand clutching one side of his head. Are you okay? Beasley asked in a concerned sounding voice. He then fired four more times, hitting Timothy in the head and killing him. They buried his body in a shallow grave Beasley had broken. and dig the night before. Brogan described to investigators where the bodies of Timothy Kern and Ralph Geiger were
埋葬的地方。警官们找到了他们两人，发现他们的伤口与布罗根的说法相符。拉尔夫头部中了一枪，而蒂莫西中了五枪。当这些信息曝光时，理查德·比斯利已经被拘留，他因未执行的逮捕令于11月16日被捕，就在布罗根·拉弗蒂被捕的同一天，距离蒂莫西·克恩被杀仅两天。调查人员在他给前房东乔·贝斯留下字条后追踪到了他。在字条中，比斯利说他听说警察一直在四处打探，想知道乔知道些什么。他让乔给他打电话，并
buried. Officers recovered them both and found that their injuries matched Brogan's version of events. Ralph had sustained one gunshot wound to his head, while Timothy had sustained five. By the time this information came to light, Richard Beasley was already in custody, having been arrested on his outstanding warrants on November 16, the same day that Brogan Rafferty was arrested, and just two days after Timothy Kern was killed. Investigators were able to track him down after he left a note for his former landlord Joe Bayes. In it, Beasley said he'd heard that police had been sniffing around and wanted to know what Joe knew. He'd asked Joe to call him and
提供了他的手机号码。侦探们让乔给比斯利打电话聊天，同时匆忙追踪到阿克伦的一所房子。事实证明，比斯利一直在租一个房间，那是他通过在Craigslist上发布“求租”广告找到的。比斯利没有开口，但对他的新住所进行的搜查发现了属于大卫·保利的许多物品，以及寄给拉尔夫·盖格的信件和上面写着拉尔夫名字的处方药瓶。在比斯利被关押候审期间，他给一位女性朋友写了一封信。
provided his cell phone number. Detectives had Joe phone Beasley for a chat while they hurriedly traced the call to a house in Akron. It turned out Beasley had been renting a room he'd found by placing a room-wanted ad on Craigslist. Beasley wasn't talking, but a search of his new residence uncovered a number of items belonging to David Paulie, as well as mail addressed to Ralph Geiger and prescription bottles with Ralph's name on them. While Beasley was held on remand, he sent a letter to a woman he was friends with.
他让她在晚上去他以前的住所，他在院子角落的树叶下藏了两台笔记本电脑。比斯利想让她销毁这两台电脑以及他藏在院子另一个地方的钱包。他附上了一张手绘地图，标明了这些物品的位置。比斯利请求他的朋友不要告诉任何人关于这封信的事，甚至编造了一个秘密代码，让她用来传达任务是否成功。比斯利的朋友没有按要求做，而是将信息交给了警察。他们找回了这些物品，结果证明是拉尔夫·盖格的钱包和大卫·保利的笔记本电脑，以及比斯利自己的笔记本电脑，里面记录了他的Craigslist活动。
He asked her to go to his former residence at nighttime, where he'd hidden two laptops under some leaves in the corner of the yard. Beasley wanted her to destroy both computers as well as a wallet he'd hidden in another area of the yard. He included a hand-drawn map of where to find these items. Beasley asked his friend not to tell anyone about his letter and even concocted a secret code she could use to communicate whether her mission had been successful or not. Instead of doing as requested, Beasley's friend handed the information over to the police. They retrieved the items, which turned out to be Ralph Geiger's wallet and David Paulie's laptop, as well as Beasley's own laptop with a record of his Craigslist activity.
理查德·比斯利坚称自己无罪，这一说法得到了他母亲的公开支持。她告诉美联社，她的儿子有一颗非常善良的心，是布罗根·拉弗蒂的导师。据她所知，两人在一起的时间都是去教堂、钓鱼、玩电子游戏和给需要的人送食物。在2013年2月下旬理查德·比斯利的审判中，检察官出示了他们从电子设备中收集的大量证据。他们还有在比斯利处发现的受害者财物，以及许多能将比斯利与犯罪联系起来的证人。几名曾与比斯利面试过虚假工作的候选人也出庭指控他，
Richard Beasley maintained his innocence, a claim which was publicly supported by his mother. She told the Associated Press that her son had a very caring heart and was a mentor to Brogan Rafferty. As far as she knew, the two spent their time together going to church, fishing, playing video games and delivering food to people in need. At Richard Beasley's trial in late February 2013, prosecutors present. an abundance of evidence they'd gleaned from electronic devices. They also had the victim's belongings that were found in Beasley's possession, as well as numerous witnesses who could link Beasley to the crimes. Several candidates who'd interviewed with Beasley for his phony job also testified against him,
那些以拉尔夫·盖格的名字认识他的朋友和熟人也出庭作证。一位前房东和一位前室友作证说，在斯科特·戴维斯前往俄亥俄州之前，比斯利就一直在谈论他的财物，包括他的哈雷戴维森摩托车。比斯利告诉他们，他竞拍了一个装有这些物品的储物单元，并希望赢得它们。调查人员得知比斯利至少使用了七部预付费手机来实施犯罪，但他们无法找回其中的大部分，也无法确凿地找到凶器。在布罗根·拉弗蒂的卧室里发现的枪支之一可能被用来杀害蒂莫西·克恩，
as did friends and acquaintances who knew him as Ralph Geiger. A former landlord and an ex-housemate testified. that Beasley had been talking about Scott Davis's possessions, including his Harley Davidson, before Scott had even left for Ohio. Beasley had told them he'd bid on a storage unit that contained the items, and he was hoping to win them. Investigators had learnt that Beasley used at least seven prepaid cell phones to conduct his crimes, but they were unable to recover most of these, nor were they able to conclusively find the murder weapon. One of the guns found in Brogan Rafferty's bedroom could have been used to kill Timothy Kern,
但这无法确定。至少还有两把枪被用来射杀其他三名受害者，但这些枪从未被找到。理查德·比斯利出庭为自己辩护。他声称他是在一个摩托车俱乐部认识拉尔夫·盖格的，并告诉拉尔夫他想改变身份的愿望。拉尔夫据称主动提出协助他改变身份。比斯利声称他不知道在那之后拉尔夫·盖格发生了什么，但暗示他可能被一个摩托车团伙杀害，其中包括布罗根·拉弗蒂的父亲以及当地一对被称为“乡村”和“县城”的父子。这正是警方在调查初期怀疑的那对组合，
but that couldn't be determined for certain. At least two other guns were used to shoot the other three victims, but these were never found. Richard Beasley took the stand in his own defence. He claimed that he'd known Ralph Geiger from a biker clubhouse and had told Ralph Ralf about his desire to change his identity. Ralph had supposedly offered up his own identity in assistance. Beasley claimed he didn't know what happened to Ralph Geiger after that, but hinted he may have been killed by a motorcycle gang that included Broken Rafferty's father and a local father and son known as country and county hood. This was the same duo that police had initially suspected in the very early stages of the investigation
调查斯科特·戴维斯谋杀未遂案时。比斯利声称，在“乡村”因事故住院后，他的儿子“县城”决定雇一名看管人来照看家庭农场。他借用比斯利的电脑在Craigslist上发布广告，并请比斯利代他面试候选人，因为他认为比斯利会给人留下更好的印象。比斯利声称他在与求职者沟通时使用了“杰克”这个名字，因为他不想冒失去刚获得的拉尔夫·盖格身份的风险。
into Scott Davis's attempted murder. Beasley claimed that after Country Hood was hospitalized due to an accident, his son, County, decided to hire a caretaker to look after the family farm. He borrowed Beasley's computer to post an ad on Craigslist and asked Beasley to interview candidates on his behalf because he thought Beasley would make a better impression. Beasley claimed he used the name Jack in communications with the job applicants, because he didn't want to risk his newly acquired Ralph Geiger identity.
比斯利坚称他见过的唯一候选人是斯科特·戴维斯。他声称实际上是斯科特掏出了枪，两人开始争夺，武器走火，击中了斯科特的胳膊。陪审团没有相信理查德·比斯利的故事。他们裁定他27项罪名成立，包括三项经过预谋和设计的加重谋杀罪和一项谋杀未遂罪。陪审团建议比斯利被判处死刑，俄亥俄州目前仍保留死刑。当受害者的家属拥抱并哭泣时，比斯利坐在他使用的轮椅上，
Beasley insisted the only candidate he'd met with was Scott Davis. He claimed that Scott was actually the one who pulled the gun and that the two had begun to struggle when the weapon went off, hitting Scott in the arm. The jurors didn't buy Richard Beasley's story. They found him guilty on 27 counts, including three counts of aggravated. murder with prior calculation and design and one count of attempted murder. The jury recommended that Beasley received the death penalty, which still exists in Ohio. As the family members of the victims embraced and wept, Beasley sat in a wheelchair he used
由于背痛，他低着头，下巴抵在胸前。法官维持了陪审团的建议，对比斯利判处了三项死刑，分别针对拉尔夫·盖格、大卫·保利和蒂莫西·克恩的谋杀案。比斯利一直上诉到美国最高法院，但均未成功。截至本集发布时，理查德·比斯利仍被关押在死囚牢房中，判决尚未执行。在布罗根·拉弗蒂被捕一周后，他同意转为污点证人指控理查德·比斯利，并向执法部门做出全面详细的供述，以换取减轻指控。他没有被指控对四名受害者中的每一位都犯有罪行，而是同意认罪，
due to his back pain, with his head facing down and his chin pressed against his chest. The judge upheld the jury's recommendation, sent him to the jury's. sentencing Richard Beasley to three death sentences for the murders of Ralph Geiger, David Paulie and Timothy Kern. Beasley unsuccessfully appealed his sentence all the way up to the US Supreme Court. As of the release of this episode, Richard Beasley remains in prison on death row, with his sentence yet to be carried out. One week after Brogan Rafferty was arrested, he agreed to turn state's witness against Richard Beasley and give a full full and detailed confession to law enforcement in exchange for receiving reduced charges. Instead of being charged for crimes against each of the four victims, he agreed to plead guilty
承认一项大卫·保利的共谋谋杀罪和一项斯科特·戴维斯的谋杀未遂罪。然而，布罗根后来改变了主意，决定接受审判。法官允许在审判中播放布罗根的供述录音。那些了解布罗根的人曾怀疑理查德·比斯利是否通过诱导和性虐待对这位青少年产生了影响。在法庭上，他的律师暗示了这种可能性，但布罗根坚决否认了这一说法。任何诱导都只是为了给布罗根提供他一直想要的父亲形象。陪审团裁定布罗根·拉弗蒂24项罪名成立，包括一项谋杀未遂罪和三项谋杀罪。
to one count of complicity to murder for David Pauli and one count of attempted murder for Scott Davis. However, Brogan later changed his mind about the deal and decided to go to trial instead. The judge allowed a recording of Brogan's confession to be played at his trial. Those close to Brogan had wondered whether Richard Beasley had achieved influence over the teenager by grooming and sexually abusing him. In court, his lawyers hinted at this possibility, but it was a claim Brogan adamantly denied. Any grooming had only been about presenting Brogan with the father figure he'd always wanted. The jury found Brogan Rafferty guilty on 24 counts, including one count of attempted
由于布罗根在犯罪时年仅16岁，他太年轻，不能被判处死刑。相反，他被判处终身监禁，不得假释。法官表示，虽然布罗根在生活中拿到了一手烂牌，但他选择了“拥抱魔鬼”。布罗根·拉弗蒂在2015年对判决提出上诉，辩称他的供述是被强迫的，并且他被剥夺了辩称自己在胁迫下行事的机会。他的上诉被驳回。2013年9月，《大西洋月刊》发表了一篇关于此案的专题文章，由记者汉娜·罗森撰写。
murder and three counts of murder. As Brogan had only been 16 at the time of the crimes, he was too young to receive the death penalty. Instead, he was sentenced to life in prison without the possibility of parole. The judge stated that while Brogan was dealt a lousy hand in life, he had chosen to, quote, embrace the devil. Brogan Rafferty appealed his sentence in 2015, arguing that his confession had been coerced, and he was denied a chance to argue that he'd acted under duress. His appeal was rejected. In September 2013, The Atlantic published a feature article about the case, written by journalist Hanna Rosen.
罗森通过一系列信件对布罗根·拉弗蒂进行了深入采访。《大西洋月刊》还发表了他们谈话的记录。在记录中，布罗根解释了他如何被理查德·比斯利操纵，以及他对受害者怀有的巨大悔恨。他谈到自己总是感受很深，但艰难的成长经历使他难以表达情感。采访以布罗根的反思结束：“总有一天，我必须坐下来，弄清楚这些谋杀案到底是怎么回事。”
Rosen interviewed Brogan Rafferty at length via a series of letters. A transcript of their conversation was also published by the Atlantic. In it, Brogan explained how he came to be so manipulated by Richard Beasley and of the great remorse he had for the victims. He spoke of how he had always felt things very deeply, but his difficult upbringing made it hard for him to express emotions. The interview concluded with Brogan reflecting, quote, Someday I'll have to sit down and make sense of these murders for what they were.
“目前，这超出了我的能力范围。总有一天，我能在自己的脑海中拼凑出这些碎片，理解这种恐怖、这种邪恶、这种不必要的痛苦背后的意义。总有一天我会做到，这会杀了我。”多位报道大卫·保利、拉尔夫·盖格和蒂莫西·克恩谋杀案的记者反思了这些受害者是如何都属于弱势群体的。他们是中年人，在某种程度上处于社会边缘。全球金融危机使他们几乎没有资源或前景，使他们容易受到听起来好得令人难以置信的机会的影响。虽然理查德·比斯利正确地识别了他们的一些弱点，
As of now, it is beyond me. Someday I'll be able to put the pieces together in my own mind and understand the meaning behind such horror, such evil, such unnecessary pain. Someday I will do this, and it shall kill me. Multiple journalists who covered the murders of David Pauli, Ralph Geiger and Timothy Kern have reflected on how the men were all part of a vulnerable group. They were middle-aged and somewhat on the margins of society. The global financial crisis had left them with few resources or prospects, making them susceptible to an opportunity that sounded too good to be true. While Richard Beasley had correctly identified some of their vulnerabilities,
但他同时也低估了他的受害者，认为当他们消失时不会有人关心。正如记者汉娜·罗森在她2013年关于此案的专题文章中指出的那样：“理查德·比斯利认为，没有人会去寻找他所针对的那些离异、生活不稳定、中年男性。但他本该更清楚的。像他的受害者一样，比斯利本人也离过婚，与孩子分开生活，而且只是零星地就业。而且像他们一样，他也与布罗根·拉弗蒂建立了强烈的代际家庭关系。”比斯利的所有谋杀受害者都有爱他们、想念他们的人，
he had also underestimated his victims by believing no one would care when they disappeared. As journalist Hanna Rosen pointed out in her 2013 feature about the case, quote, Richard Beasley had believed that no one would come looking for the divorced, unsettled, middle-aged men he was targeting. But he should have known better. Like his victims, Beasley was himself divorced and lived apart from his child and was only sporadically employed. And like them, he too had created an intense surrogate family relationship with Brogan Rafferty. All of Beasley's murder victims had people who loved them, missed them,
并且在他们停止联系时肯定会注意到。大卫·保利曾计划圣诞节去探望他的双胞胎妹妹黛博拉，并每天与他最好的朋友克里斯通话50次。当他从他们的生活中消失时，两人很快就开始询问并展开调查。黛博拉在法庭上直接对理查德·比斯利说：“你夺走了我最好的朋友、知己和我的双胞胎兄弟。”拉尔夫·盖格有一个名叫凯西的妹妹，他总是在生日和节日与她联系。当她的生日过去而没有接到拉尔夫的电话时，凯西给拉尔夫打电话询问他的情况。
and definitely noticed when they stopped making contact. David Paulie had been planning to visit his twin sister Deborah for Christmas and spoke to his best friend Chris 50 times a day. When he disappeared from their lives, both were quick to make inquiries and start investigating. Deborah addressed Richard Beasley directly in court, telling him, You took my best friend, confidant, and my twin. Ralph Geiger had a sister named Kathy whom he always made contact with on birthdays and holidays. When her birthday passed with no call from Ralph, Kathy phoned Ralph to check on him.
电话直接转到了语音信箱。凯西随后联系了其他家庭成员和拉尔夫的朋友，看看是否有人与他联系过。有人告诉她拉尔夫的新工作以及他在那里没有手机信号。当警察后来打电话通知凯西拉尔夫被谋杀时，那是凯西一生中最糟糕的电话。拉尔夫还与一位名叫萨默·罗利的朋友关系密切，她对他来说就像女儿一样。萨默比拉尔夫小30岁，是在她叛逆的青少年时期认识他的。
The call went straight to voicemail. Kathy followed up with other family members and Ralph's friends to see if anyone had been in touch with him. Someone told her about Ralph's new job and how he didn't have cell service there. When police later called Kathy to inform her that Ralph had been murdered, it was the worst phone call of Kathy's life. Ralph also had a close relationship with a friend named Summer Rowley, who was like a daughter to him. Summer was 30 years younger than Ralph and had met him when she was a rebellious teenager.
拉尔夫把萨默带在身边，教她如何为自己做营养餐和做一些简单的建筑工作。很快，她就开始和他一起工作。到萨默25岁时，她已经订婚并生下了一个女婴，拉尔夫对她来说就像祖父一样。萨默至今仍在家里的壁炉架上放着一张拉尔夫和她女儿的照片。蒂莫西·克恩的失踪立即被他的孩子们注意到，他们开始疯狂地给他打电话和发短信。蒂莫西与他的儿子们有着极其亲密的关系。尽管他们几乎已经成年，但他仍然称他们为“我的宝贝”。
Ralph had taken Summer under his wing, teaching her how to cook nutritious meals for herself and do minor construction work. Soon, she'd started working alongside him. By the time Summer was 25, she had gotten engaged and had a baby girl, to whom Ralph was like a grandfather. Summer still keeps a photo of Ralph and her daughter on a mantle in her home. Timothy Kern's disappearance was immediately noticed by his children, who started calling and texting him frantically. Timothy had an incredibly close bond with his sons. Even though they were almost grown up, he still referred to them as my babies.
做出远离他们的决定是痛苦的，他反复告诉他们，他不想离开他们。他为自己的孩子们感到骄傲，以至于他向遇到的每个人都吹嘘他们。在他去新工作后，蒂莫西的一个儿子给他发了一条短信：“我爱你，我想你，我为你感到骄傲。我为你感到骄傲。祝你好运。”第二天早上，蒂莫西回信说：“醒了给我发短信。爱你。马上出发。”理查德·比斯利唯一的幸存受害者斯科特·戴维斯，因比斯利试图杀他时造成的伤害，留下了慢性疼痛和手臂里的钢板。他在法庭上两次面对他未遂的杀手，
Making the decision to move far away from them had been painful, and he repeatedly told them that he didn't want to leave them. He was so proud of his children that he bragged about them to everyone he met. After he left for his new job, one of Timothy's son sent him a text that read, I love you, I miss you, I'm proud of you. I'm proud of him. you. Good luck. The next morning, Timothy messaged back. Text me when you wake up. Love you. Leaving soon. Richard Beasley's sole surviving victim, Scott Davis, has been left with chronic pain and a plate in his arm from the injury sustained when Beasley tried to kill him. He faced his would-be killer twice in court,
作为证人作证，后来发表了受害者影响陈述。斯科特说，比斯利谋杀案受害者的家属对他来说已经像家人一样。在提到比斯利所谓的信仰时，斯科特说：“我相信你知道十诫。你打破了所有这些，但有三条浮现在脑海中。你是一个骗子、一个小偷和一个杀人犯。你说你认识上帝。还没有。我是那个逃脱的人。靠着上帝的恩典，这将困扰你余生在4x8的牢房里。”本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
testifying as a witness and later delivering a victim impact statement. Scott said that the families of Beasley's murdered victims had become like family to him. In a reference to Beasley's supposed faith, Scott stated, I'm sure you know the Ten Commandments. You've broken all of them, but three come to mind. You're a liar, a thief and a murderer. You say you know God. Not yet. I am the one that got away. By the grace of God, that will haunt you the rest of your life in your 4x8 cell. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
作为证人作证，随后发表了受害者影响陈述。斯科特说，比斯利谋杀案受害者的家属已经变得像他的家人一样。在提到比斯利所谓的信仰时，斯科特说，我相信你知道十诫。你已经打破了所有这些诫命，但有三条浮现在脑海中。你是一个骗子、一个小偷和一个杀人犯。你说你认识上帝。还没有。我是那个逃脱的人。靠着上帝的恩典，这将困扰你的余生，在你的4x8英尺牢房里。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。